pop
[Musique]
ah oui à la population tient remise des
prix aux lauréats du concours de pets lé
minium enrayer le feu juillet 1938 à
chaque heure du soir dans les selles des
faits aussi de ses profits à loos à
l'issue de cette cérémonie un vin
d'honneur sera offert aux toits
conscrits de notre siège qui ont été
reconnus bon aulas service signée mère
et prix bradés
bonjour
quoi vous dire que les sauvegardes sont
en grève depuis dix jours c'est une
coutume ici
dans le village tout le monde se dit
bonjour au revoir
le souffle coupé par son élégance et il
est pas mal plus sa bonne forme la vie
comment la petite boîte extrêmement à
l'actuel moi tu m'accompagnes pas la
même non ma chérie je respecte beaucoup
de conviction religieuse m'écoute je
vais passer à la boulangerie chercher la
tarte et puis on serait tous les cafés
tabacs et la glace yonnais
je ne peux plus tu m'accompagnes taux
zéro balle
les pollens 14 ans le jeune fille de
notre client sur iphone qui va coller
c'est la petite là dans ton prochain
roman non un mot c'est ce qui parfois
pour créer un personnage d'une situation
[Musique]
non
son mari vient d'acheter la propriété de
la bonne cuisine s'appelle change rien
vraiment il a eu un enfant tombe paris
soir
ayrault
[Musique]
g pourquoi tu veux pas de ton gars on se
marie parce que ça m'intéresse pas
d'avoir une fille à la maison
oui mais ça l'intéressera peut-être pas
du tout ça va bien sa femme et lui faire
une commande il aime aller pisser
elle est habillée comme un guignol à mon
avis c'est une artiste qu'est ce qui te
fait dire ça elle sait pas faire la
tarte au bonjour je viens chercher ma
tasse à café d'adrien qui s'en est
occupé et malheureusement il n'est pas
là alors bougez pas j'ai vu dans la cour
je vais lui demander directement avec la
cram merci au revoir madame
tu as bien cinq minutes est sortie si on
peut causer
oui oui ma mère est occupé ici bas on
est tranquille c'est quelque chose à me
dire adrien ça dépend bon bah écoute
depuis qu'on s'est rencontrés à la
passer du temps chez monsieur pradel moi
j'ai réfléchi ça me plairait bien d'être
boulangère katie holmes et je n'aurais
jamais osé de poser la question on
hésite on sait que tu en parles aux
valeurs c'était d'accord bien sûr que je
suis d'accord seulement il ya ma mère au
poids ta mère tu es plus la gamme taquet
lui dire carrément j'épouse nicole
qu'est ce que j'entends est pas allé par
20 city lui
j'épouse nicole ah oui ben et c'est un
peu pour voir
t'es pas d'accord t'es pas l'innocent tu
sais très bien que je sois belle fille
mais adrien lui une femme sinon ça pompe
à louvain non mais pour que tu cries ici
c'est moi qui commande
écoutez moi madame vous jamais je veux
que cette fixe hendaye et vite vite
bonbons te fâche pas les attends je vais
lui parler
n'ayez jamais l'enfant mesure il va vous
voyez le mien bientôt 25 ans une fentre
de misère alors c'est décidé
tu veux pas que j'épouse nicole j'ai dit
non et des choses plusieurs genres de
rechercher la tarte aux pommes de
monsieur et rapporte moi aussi des pages
on n'est plus assez dans la boutique
est-ce que c'est compris oui maman
[Musique]
tian bonjour à vous connaissez au nom on
va aux pensées ici un parisien s'est
tout de suite repéré il paraît que vous
cherchez une femme de ménage savez ça
aussi envoyé par mademoiselle mignon
mignon
la postière elle fait toujours tout et
elle a parlé à monsieur le maire qui va
vous envoyer de ces petite servante
[Musique]
heureux de vous connaître et ça valait 1
chardy aux maires la fesci bergerac
maître d'école si on chantait seiu merci
et ce mobile et mon dieu
la blanc-sec un blanc sec j'arrive à je
voudrais tout de suite vous poser une
question à vous en prie je me suis
laissé dire par la postière la
demoiselle qui sait tout
ils ont presque tous elle prétend que
vous avez acheté une maison à saint
gondran pour avoir la paix quand vous
écrivez vos rendements ça c'est alors
vous allez vivre ici plusieurs mois par
an oui bien sûr
pauline darles a mentionné mme rivasi
cher monsieur vous êtes un écrivain
célèbre trilogie suis enfin votre nom
dans tous les journaux alors vous devez
connaître à paris des gens est très
importante et si vous pouviez nous
obtenir un petit coup de piston ben ça
c'est pas impossible
bon alors supposer que bergerac viennent
me voir la semaine prochaine avec un
petit problème d'adduction d'eau mais ça
m'étonnerait fort parce que les
instituteurs ont toujours posé des
problèmes de robinets
[Musique]
enfin bon vieux sites à l'aube et y toi
quand on a défendu de fréquenter maman
je serai là moi aujourd'hui je fais tu
fais tu parles à ton père lui annonce
que je vais voir nicole cela père dit
donne moi ça attention adrien si tu mets
cette casquette c'est la guerre
t'inquiètes pas j'ai le moral je suis
prêt tu vois jeunes à brie sous la ligne
maginot et moi j'ouvre les hostilités
[Musique]
mais c'était seulement 2,1 millions de
parisiens c'est court toujours
c'est normal chez bien des cycles être
non mais à paris je suis toujours assis
derrière mon bureau alors qu'ils aient
décidé de pédaler pour garder la forme
dites moi mais vous lisez le journal les
autres races oui j'adore me tenir au
courant de l'actualité ça c'est mon fils
alors je lis tout ce qui me passe entre
les mains les faire par les cartes
postales prospectus en face à me
distrait vous aurez aussi les enveloppes
annonce à jamais même si une lettre
promet d'être passionnante
le courrier pour moi c'est sacré et bien
bravo je vous décerne un prix de vertu
mon dernier roman avec une jolie
dédicace avec une dédicace
oh ça c'est vraiment gentil monsieur ben
on va vous doit verser à wazemmes
millions vous êtes ma gazette
grâce à vous je connais tous les détails
de la lutte qui oppose la boulangère
avec son enfant martyr
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je suivais
boulard depuis dimanche dernier
régnant commence à rien vous m'aviez dit
il va y avoir un drame n'a justement
rien si vous saviez comme je suis
contrarié
adrien n'a toujours pas revenus comme
pas depuis fin juillet est d'après vous
la boulangère ne montrer aucun signe de
faiblesse rocade et j'avais pourtant 66
un joker en colère et d'un croc table
adrien maintenant
on va en parler vous avez si tu veux
mais je suis tombé
hu
tu te fais mal
et non mais ça va
je suis d'accord me contrarie paps quand
tu me contrarie samba la normale
adrienne koutouan tous ouvre le tiroir
on comprend ce machin va tu va pédaler
jusqu'à précis ni tu vas voir le
pharmacien actuellement de ce truc là
c'est les pastilles ils vont sauver
couche quand juste est enceinte c'est
pas la même chose
c'était peu qu'elles n'étaient pas
contrarier et baden mais chez mon grand
écran bien avant 7 heures pour
l'ouverture du magasin
16h19
mais qu'est ce qui se pense génie est
malade ça ne m'étonne pas senti seul
effet par les quatorze passion vous ne
trouvez pas normal qu adriana il se
marier pas contre la volonté de sa mère
au second 3 yona qui se croient encore
au moyen-âge tient l'homme l'a justement
c'est moi je suis en retard t'inquiète
pas mon gars comprend la situation et
aller chercher le docteur en son nom il
a dû aller jusqu à précigné pour
apporter des médicaments
d'après ce que nous a dit holland voilà
comment va-t-elle c'est pas brillant qui
leur apporte ses pastilles mais non le
pharmacien m'a dit qu'il y avait un
temps que les faits plus il faut
appliquer doctorants cela mais non mais
mais mais voudra pas recevoir je m'en
charge a dit le chercher monsieur remis
par monsieur ribar je viens d'écouter la
tsf ça y est à munich
ils ont signé l'accord pendant la nuit
c'est vrai merci madame ignore ces
gentilles très gentil je savais que ça
vous intéresserait
ça m'intéresse non c'est non
je suis drôle monsieur le maire semblait
pas apprécié la chose ces histoires là
nous aussi ça nous concerne pas non ce
qui me turlupine
c'est mon problème l'adduction en eau
déconcertant madame liban ça y est à
munich
ils ont signé l'accord parfait dit
vraiment chéri ce que tu dirais d'une
omelette au finistère pour les dîners le
même adn que l'accord est signé ne rompt
pas la guerre
oui tant mieux je reviens j'ai oublié la
sauce au mans décidément aux demoiselles
mignon nous sommes les seuls ici que la
paix intéresse vous pouvez vous
recoucher maintenant je vois ce qu'il va
pas pour sa part le docteur ce qui va
passer les stops non non non non non
c'est surtout le coeur tu peux envoyer
derrière ça va surtout de suite ce n'est
pas grave
simplement je vais faire une vingtaine
de piqûres
avouez que vous avez de la chance d'ici
le 15 octobre on vous allez me voir tous
les jours il est content il va nous
prendre des sous aux aubes alain boulard
depuis le temps que je vous achète du
père vous devez bien une petite
ristourne or il paraît que tu m'as
trouvé une vendeuse
ah oui elle est belle 14 c'est une dame
du village non non mais t'inquiète pas
je lui les champs
président on s'est arrangé c'est
quelqu'un de mon âme personnellement il
me conviendrait fort bien jette un coup
d'oeil discret non mais qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'il reste à quoi elle fait rien de
mal elle prend un bain de soleil
tu trouves pas ça ravissant m'était
complètement malade mais si je ramène à
la maison une fille qui pour lehmann
soleil ma mère elle va mourir d'une
crise d'apoplexie non mais tu ta mère ne
verra jamais elle est couchée à léo des
biens je te présente attend pas drancy
décolleté sur le plan commercial cet
excellent un peu le genre de clientèle
qui fréquente la boutique quoi c'est une
boulangerie c'est pas les milices ont
rendu ce matin n'ont donc pas et à faire
la pudeur dialogue avec ta vu là-bas
allongé sur mon banc la jupe en l'air
rassurez vous je ne ferai pas rond et
l'église de voir la clientèle
j'espère bien de travailler chez
caribéen tusa le boucher pressé ni
tenait la caisse
à un détail mais très important pour toi
modèle c'est faire des piqûres
alors en cas d'urgence pour ta mère ça
peut la sauver
ouais ça c'est intéressant à lait vendu
tout lui donne 40 fois par semaine et il
a nourri à midi ça va tu es content et
moi je vous pose une question précise
quand vous déciderez vous achetez une
lance d'incendié
quand nous aurons genou ah ben oui c'est
normal ça a abattu comme ça vous langer
sa mère a encore dû faire une colère à
la malheureuse elle va mourir et tout ça
parce que son office vous épousez la
petite martin yelle vont épouser un
autre
c'est ce que vous dites
dit que la petite martin en aime un
autre allons bon
comment savez vous cela ils s'écrivent
tous les jours en secret mais moi je
vois pas si leurs maîtres je veux la
boulangère lui remonter le moral en lui
annonçant qu adrien est évincé a
doucement doucement nous ne nous
emballons pas mademoiselle mignon une
question hawaïen daisy j'adore ça vous
avez constaté que ces jeunes gens ces
crimes pour l'instant ce sont les
meilleurs clients bien mais vont-ils se
marier
voilà vous entendez mademoiselle mignon
suppose vous avez raison curé avant de
parler à la boulangère ils nous font une
certitude
je vais interroger la petite marque non
non non pas vous non si vous permettez
c'est moi qui vais lui parler en quel
honneur j'ai l'habitude de recevoir les
confessions ici mademoiselle c'est une
coutume chaque dimanche à la messe ont
distribué du pain béni est ce pas là et
de faire un tour de rôle par les fidèles
du village ainsi la semaine dernière
c'était le tour de ma soeur hortense a
proposé ce qu'elle vous a payé comme été
je vais voir ce que monsieur boulard a
menti sur son passé
elle est très bien cette petite et
croyez moi je ne trouve jamais ça c'est
une fille sérieuse
adrien mais j'en reviens monsieur
boulard non sa mèrele réclament mairie
centrale m'ouvrir ne soyez pas timides
mon petit a décidé de dépêcher vous
monsieur poulat votre mère vous réclame
du bon enfin bénazech à propos votre
soeur ne nous a pas payé de kabylie a et
ben c'est bien ce que je pense et la
jolie de repasser vouloir merci beaucoup
mais je resterai service lancé en bêta
tout à fait voir n'a jamais annulé
détendent un peu comme c'est pas le
moment
même villa rémois jean prix le respect
difficile alors
je peins non plus je suis très inquiet
son état s'est brusquement aggravé il
est ce que vous pourriez lui faire une
série de pics hulot quant à la nuit bah
oui c'est vraiment utile indispensable
on va c'est entendu merci mon aussi la
dette
tu vas dormir rabat faut bien je la lui
faire trois piqûres dans la nuit je
t'avertis il ya un bruit qui court
nicole martin laisserait tomber le
boulanger ah bon il paraît qu'elle va
épouser un jeune qui travaille aux
chemins de fer après ceni dont je te dis
ça parce que si ça t'intéresse est de
devenir boulangère dit c'est pas bête ce
passé ça va être fournie voilée et puis
là c'est la niche où je me repose quand
mon père en cuir
elles reviennent plus douillet à vous
proposer
non mais vous allez voir le matelas est
très très très très bon mais avec vous
faut vraiment assisté pour se faire
comprendre
pardon vous inquiétez pas je vais
m'arranger autrement et patrons regarder
bah oui c'est une chemise bon alors je
le mets sur 11 heures pour la première
piqûre
et quand je descends va ici pour
travailler à 4 heures je vous
réveillerez pour la deuxième piqûre
puis je montrais me reposer jusqu'à la
troisième piqûre c'est d'accord
ce à quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya vous avez
une bouche a tout de même vous avez
remarqué quelque chose on va rester là
je me déshabille
c'est vous qui sentait bon comme ça
vous aimez c'est un parfum qui s'appelle
flore du bengale
on m'a dit c'est violent mais distinguer
away j'enlève ma robe
bah oui quand on veut se coucher on se
déshabille
on veut il est parti on va alors ça
c'est vraiment le roi des corniches ans
boulanger et qu'il arrive plaque
l'auteur est gérée monsieur verges avec
1 somptuosité la municipalité restoring
honor jeunes ont aussi levé il va y
avoir foule ce soir parce que toute
cette deuxième dimanche d'octobre yaba
la seconde bougeait tout jeune fils à la
sacristie eymétois en tenue pour une
extrême onction au nom pour maintenant
mon petit projet l'extrême en soit le
seul sacre de moi qu'ils ne puissent pas
attendre aller à les battre
j'te devrait 46 allez trotte et rejoint
mois chez la boulangère
mais vous craignez pas que ça lui fasse
un choc pas si tu lui dis le curé vient
de sauter le bonjour en passant vous
pourriez peut-être revenir un peu plus
tard
non non non non j'ai également contraint
de lutter contre elles il n'y a pas une
minute à perdre un peu comme mon enfant
de choeur arrivera vous me direz que ce
soit sur cette chaise et de ne pas
fernando ici à ta mère dans la bonne
humeur
maintenant
maman
regarde qui viennent dire un petit
bonjour
si mal que ça mais non ce genre de
visite d'ariel inquiétant loeb après
vous ça va extrême onction
c'est ainsi de bonne santé
non je ne veux pas jusque là à les
héberger
il faut croire au miracle cite moi je
demande qu'il y aurait je vous y attends
attends rien arranger ça madame boulard
je ne devrais pas vous en parler
vous ne vouliez pas du mariage peut
projeter votre fils je veux toujours
peur et bien soyez heureuse
la petite nicole martin a changé d'avis
et leur les poussins autres faut dire ça
un trille or voilà boulard non je vous y
conduit ce secret parce que vous êtes
parce que vous êtes mais mais vous ne
devez pas la répéter si c'est trop beau
il faut à trotter ça mon grand poids
haute finalement vous voulez le faire
mourir de chagrin à peynier procurer ça
vous fera deux enterrements dans la même
semaine
[Musique]
adriano
m
je
[Musique]
et
mais
[Musique]
oui
gc
[Musique]
alors ne me trouble et par jour à paris
un bon monsieur le maire ouais bon
adversaire une avancée suis battu sans
discussion
allez vas-y tu ferais c'est chacun son
tour tout le monde s'amuse
voilà le nom que vous avez gagné pouvoir
l'accrocher au mieux vaut en effet déjà
ça ne veut pas dire la deuxième lame
riva je veux la rendre dans les familles
républicaines les enfants adorent les
marquises
stoner et c'est la musique si la
boulangère est en train de mûrir way we
qu'elle allait mieux
non mentionnées dans le coma que cet
après midi alors j'ai tout ce tintamarre
en patrouille à fond alors c'est
demander d'arrêter la musique oui le bal
vient à peine de commencer
je vous arrête il va y avoir une émeute
c'est épouvantable
[Musique]
on va peut-être aller dire un mot gentil
où donc
oui les interrogations c'est pas bon
[Musique]
alors et le vit ces tous derniers
instants
c'est curieux j'étais persuadé qu'il
aurait une fin digne d'un personnage de
balzac
on est dévasté le charivari tout devient
dérisoire auteurs majeurs ne risquent
plus pourquoi votre femme series à
ouvrir sur une musique torreilles
cameron
[Musique]
et
bénédicte tous dominus des os qui sera
we have is activités suscitent les
actionnaires
elle est vexatoire nous savons tous nos
vies et nous avons david ferrer
[Musique]
mais demain on aura mis fin à la série
centraméricain je n'irai pas l'accepter
il a notamment offert aussi à une
attaque il n'a jamais c'est une
tellement on fait là c'était du piémont
lorsque membres la boulangère vous
donner juste assez pour frais de cigares
et jamais il n'a plus fini inversement
image alors à l'habitude a dit amer
était une sale égoïste elle n'a pensé
qu'à de garder pour elle toute seule de
mama tu as tu vas me faire le plaisir
d'aller trouver ta fameuse nichols le
pour yves avoir un choc
il paraît qu'elle en aime un autre temps
ballpad par la suite une demi heure plus
tard voilà qu'arrive la demoiselle
lumignons qui était déjà au courant mais
ce qu'avait dit aulas bien entendu la
postière elle aime bien mon patron alors
allah pour voulu qui délire d'une cloche
en allant faire sa demande à une fille
qui serait fichu de sa gueule alors il
lui a passé le morceau votre nichols
qu'elle lui a dit votre nicole elle
épouse a nommé michel racho au bon dieu
naturellement il a refusé de la croire
alors à lui a montré un journal nous
apprenons avec plaisir du bon dieu et ça
se terminait par la date du mariage le
21 novembre 1938 à y accueillir le
patron il faisait une de ces tirelires
mais c'est fini l'a récupéré à bord ont
déjà fermé la boutique il m'a dit avec
le sourire
j'ai pas besoin de chercher une femme
pour tenir le ménage et la caisse
puisque vous êtes là et a dit ça oui mon
petit lulu
bon alors tu veux mon opinion tous les
espoirs sont permis
je le crois
[Musique]
on salue la bourse salue d'ailleurs j'ai
oublié mes cigarettes à malause si c'est
oui tu n'avais pas roulé travailler tu
sais ce que tu aimerais vraiment acheté
une dizaine de paquets d'avants
maintenant on peut toucher un browser et
a justement j'ai à faire et compte faire
le boulanger à 50 pensez vraiment avec
une misère quand j'aurai payé le docteur
épuré g.skill brestois n'ont 453 france
et pas drôle la mer aura travaillé toute
sa vie pour ne laisser 450 points francs
alors toi qui voulais acheter une
bagnole alors là c'est fini voilà fradj
épouser une fille qui est beaucoup
d'argent ça doit pas être impossible
bon comme je suis tu as entendu il veut
épouser des filles qui a du pognon
taille est bonne le sort de faire
changer d'avis à 7 heures j'arrive à la
boutique et à cette personne j'attaque
d'autre les deux yeux
mais celui que j'aime le mieux
il m'appelle je croyais musée du
chanteur maintenant je suis là vous en
ferons part oui vous passez par la cour
excusez moi vous n'aviez pas fini de
faire votre toilette ça va et puis là je
me fais un peu les yeux c'est plus
flatteur non je vous plais comme ça ma
foi si ça vous amuse
je trouve pas ça mais non voilà votre
semaine
mais bon c'est mon gars qui file à la je
voulais vous demander est ce que vous
aimeriez que je porte des bas noirs on
vous dit ça ce qui est beaucoup d'amis
qui s'appelait dans mes mains
surtout quand on ne te lis jambes vous
aimeriez mademoiselle la dette
ça va s'arranger du travail ça va comme
tu veux mais depuis ça peut être facile
ah oui je te le dis il est coriace
pourtant cette mesure j'ai attaqué et
l'apport réagi à un arbre il s'est sauvé
dans avoir bu son café au lait
mon avis c'est parce qu'elle est timide
je m'en fous je leur ai quand même je te
fais le con finir un petit peu lure
pas trop buvez pas votre café vous êtes
froid ça c'est bien là vous êtes à petit
cette gentille vous mettais mon bol sur
le panneau cuisinière police kencho à
terme et 50 baguette un ba oui la
commande que j'ai passé à l'avant 2 mais
n'a pas parlé ça par exemple à nos
abonnés
mais pas de télé 50 baguette pour le
déjeuner de mariage de ma soeur à faire
d'un problème technique
je vous en prie soyez polis dans la vie
mentale
je fais toutes mes excuses bah c'est pas
ça qui me donnera ses 50 baguette
à l'aller les fichiers mal quand ça m'a
fait du mal mais n'a pu m'arranger des
poignets l'heure des baguettes midi
d'ailleurs nous cache tout d'abord
c'était avant de calmer les nerfs
voulait casser des siennes
[Musique]
mais vous faites exprès pour peupler
maladresse et peut-être envoyé mais ça
qu'on dit papa à présent j'ai travaillé
quelqu'un qui oeuvre dans la boutique
le sound temps passe
masterclass et sur ma tombe c'est vous
mademoiselle est belle comme un exemple
alors tout fait mais ça va pas mais
qu'est ce qui vous pend dans tes dents
match au masters l'a habillé en tant qu'
noise d'artagnan garder sa culotte
moi je suis dans la chambre vue et puis
si ça n'avait encaissé que ça du
champagne mais vous c'est la boule non
je viens seulement de faire pardonner
les bêtises de ce matin
alors ça n'en est pas question 7h10
qu'est ce qui se passe à vous le voyez
bien la boulangerie n'est pas encore
ouvert ça recommence oui mais ce que si
c'est pas la faute de génie j'espère que
qu'adrien n'est pas malade
c'était de suicide ni eau du pot de
bêtises pas la porte mais coeur on s'en
fout
oui je sais hier encore le boulanger a
oublié de faire du pain et aujourd'hui
il a récidivé à bon politicien titan
village d'émotion elle considère oui
comment oui parce que du grand compte
voilà deux jours que le club de brive
une femme et même du pape
une boulangerie fermée pour cause de
luxure graves aux paroissiens sont scott
à 10 et on fait attention hippolyte tes
administrés sont très mécontents c'est
le reproche aux prochaines élections tu
dois réagir si vous ne voulez pas que
certains se plaignent auprès de
monseigneur dubois vous devez intervenir
vous devez dire assez tôt dès la
lubricité tu va les trouver cette ville
de dire maintenant ça suffit
enfin les diabétiques il est des mots
c'est votre affaire
d'accord de monaco pour ta voix du maire
de saint laurent il maintient de l'ordre
au public ça te regarde
d'accord je m'en occupe
[Musique]
m
bonjour monsieur acheté la wii gremaud à
la bénodet non vous permettez je
voudrais lui parler d'abord vous voulez
discuter avec cette fille qui n'a aucune
pudeur l'habitude de m'entretenir avec
les pécheresses celle-ci ne vous
écoutera pas mais pourquoi donc s'il
vous plaît allez anticlérical excusez
moi une débauche et j'aurais dû penser
que les têtes vos amis là bas que terre
quoi qu'il en soit je lui parlais du
polish quoi faire fais moi confiance
j'avais l'écraser avec le poids prône
autorités municipales laïque et
républicaine
la demoiselle aux dettes
[Musique]
vernaudon
bon ballon
la séance est ouverte clotaire flandre
est frappé comme la foudre guerrier
entre la demoiselle fait partie du
conseil municipal
non mais j'assiste à cette séance ok ça
m'intéresse oui c'est une séance
publique et la loi et aux valides
c'est impressionnant la minute aggrave
tiento est grave parce que par votre
faute de 5 entre anet sont condamnés à
manger leur pain quotidien des heures
tout à fait fantaisiste affaires terme
était dans mademoiselle je ne peux pas
te dire est que le ravitaillement mes
administrés soient tributaires des
voitures enfermant les qualifs c'est
pourquoi je vous prie de bien vouloir
faire vos valises
vous rigolez pas du tout je même disposé
à employer la force la force
écoutez monsieur pradesh et bouffant
vous connaissez une loi qui vous
autorise à venir
votre bête là bas non mais je m'appuie
sur aucune loi avec moi j'aime
simplement sur le caractère de ses
contrats nets qui déteste le scandale à
tel point que à chaque fois vous en gros
c'est une de vos servante tout le monde
évite d'en parler ça vous amuse à menzel
mignon que joueur ça le ciel mer bon bah
je crois qu n'est pas un as dit non vous
avez noté que je refuse de quitter le
village est férié et bien c'est parfait
messieurs changé bien le faire c'est la
bérézina qui voulait lui zappeurs
fédéral alors maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire je peux donner mon avis voilà
où nous en sommes il existe un moyen de
nous débarrasser de cette demoiselle
je sais quelle merde envie d'aller
travailler
honnête je cherchais et qu'est ce que tu
fais avec un manteau et une vanille tue
pas ouais mais c'est idiot je suis très
heureux ça file gaulliste may cry
gaulliste mais qu'est ce que tu racontes
quand on veut partager sa vie avec
quelqu'un on est égoïste
l'écrivain était tout fait castrer
n'être que je t'ai laissé sous son
oreiller c'est pas possible
quand on faisait des petits projets
d'avis et lorraine a vu d'or lâche ses
balises est expliqué on a fait une très
jolie situation à sa montre ou non paris
fait la gérante d'un petit café juste en
face de la gare du nord il paraît que
c'est le rendez vous de toutes les
grandes vedettes du cinéma français ou
joyau lillois
je vais gagner beaucoup de sous mais ici
aussi tu peux en gagner
on vous raconte pas d'histoires bonjour
tu as dit à vue lui que ta mère en
trente ans de travail à la économiser
450 3 francs et alors quand on s'aime
l'argent n'a aucune importance mais t'es
dingue
rodez mais je regrette - la misère ça ne
fait pas ton qui nous reste écoute pas
d'attendrissement mon biquet on s'est
fait plaisir tous les deux ça pouvait
pas durer toujours
qui sinon pas gentiment se dit m
c'est vite dit bureau j'arrive au lycée
bureau voilà que les autres ceux là sont
ceux qui ne vont pas la nes oui ils sont
pas nombreux et très gros tu veux leur
avait donné au brésil une habitude mais
laissez moi remercier au nom de la
municipalité d'être venu ici à dimanche
matin il faut que le boulanger se marque
il faut qu'il aille à notre bureau j'ai
trouver une épouse
et pour cela nous avons besoin de votre
coopération
mais je veux dire de votre aide alors
voilà ce que vous allez faire vous allez
interroger vont maintenant reprendre
seul les copines de vos grandes soeurs
pour savoir si elle ne l'était pas lieu
une demoiselle susceptible de devenir
boulanger vous avez compris alors là je
l'avais sur un billet le lendemain
loisel révolte année à votre avis
et attention c'est un secret entre nous
je vous demande d'agir avec la plus
grande discrétion comme comme de
véritables de conspirateurs et vous
allez comprendre pourquoi il y à déjà
quelqu'un d'autre qui essaye de trouver
une fiancée adrian et c'est notre curé
sont pas républicains ces petits mes
enfants ne vivent des minutes
l'historique les catholiques vont avoir
leur candidate
nous les laïcs ne devons aussi avoir un
autre alors pour ça je fais confiance au
dévouement tu vaux petits coeurs
républicain oui mes chers paroissiens
vous l'avez tous compris notre boulanger
ne peut sans une compagne suffire à la
peine
l'éternel lui même l'a dit n'est pas bon
que l'homme soit seul que chacun d'entre
vous sans emploi dont chrétiennement à
trouver une solution à cet angoissant
problème il nous faut une boulanger
ainsi souhaite au nom du père
segovia whitmore
tu en penses
le quotidien mais monsieur le curé
discute pas mon fils maillot tout le
monde te le dira il te faut une épouse
et celle ci c'est le bon dieu qui
s'envoient bondues et moi on n'a pas les
mêmes
je trouve cécile un peu forte un peu
amène à une belle âme
et puis c'est une vraie jeune fille
alors là vous voyez ça me surprend pas
souri lui il te regarde
oh là là là là mais c'est le curé vous à
10 6 ans marie davy reconnaît beaucoup
d'enfants ont annoncé les catholiques
ont déjà trouvé une nouvelle candidate
c'est décourageant marquer si si elle
est aussi laide que la première est ce
qui m'inquiète c'est que nous aurons
personne n'arrive à savoir comment j'ai
pas pensé plus tôt
bénévolat notre futur boulangère qui est
marita ça tu peux pas la connaître elle
habite à 18 kilomètres d'ici c'est une
demoiselle
oui certainement j'avais des mariages je
le saurai et sans être mariée elle a
peut-être un amoureux marie on sport et
se renseigner discrètement tu veux t'en
chargé je peux pas à moi tout le monde
le connaît là-bas bon va leur envoyer
quelqu'un qui passe inaperçu ou quoi
oh voilà
la garder
c'est la blonde qui conduit
elle a une voiture mais pas les noms
sahraouis dont elle est pas mal mais tu
parles c'est le dernier modèle du salon
de l'auto alors je pars de la demoiselle
monsieur bergerette 16e pradel notable
si adrien notre boulanger nous elle
venir on va faire connaissance en buvant
un verre benoît hamon sur i bar vous
savez la nouvelle ça m'a plus tard mais
je vous connais oui nous allons avoir
une boulangère savez vous dénichez va
vous connaissez le père du héros à wil
maraîchers oui bien sûr et bien
autrefois il a fricoté avec la maman de
la jeune fille
il est allé chercher la petite à
cartignies le pont elle s'appelle marie
si c'est une orpheline ses parents
étaient boulangers
oui tout ça est très intéressant mais
est-ce qu'elle plaît allez rien comment
ne savait pas un modèle millions non
mais attention j'ai une excuse ça fait
exactement 23 minutes khadriya et marie
sont face à face au dollar
alors est-ce que tu rappes arras
j'ai trouvé un peu froide ah oui le
mariage ça ira mieux ats elle m'a dit
rapides la voiture l'avait de l'argent
de côté
alors dis moi pourquoi ne s'est pas
marié plus tôt au lieu que ce soit au
courant voilà l homme est un homme marié
qui s'est noyé au printemps dernier en
voulant sauver un petit garçon voilà
marié oui alors à quatre yeux pour aucun
garçon ne veut l'épouser
forcément tout le monde connaît son
aventure à l'excès petit mais ici à 50
ans c'est pas pareil de comprendre on
peut ignorer ce qu'elle a fait mais vrai
on peut mais moi je n'ignore plus
puisque tu me dis mais non mais non
atteinte à temps ce qui compte c'est que
tu puisses être censé l'ignorer
d'où tu saisis la finesse tu le sais
mais personne ne peut accuser de le
savoir
et comme ça à ton honneur est sauf
c'est ça une boutique ça peut toujours
s'arranger
et il paraît qu'il a une très jolie
clientèle marie écoute moi tu veux
quitter le pays ne plus travailler chez
les autres et bien ici tu seras la
patronne oui c'est intéressant
et puis tu es vu le genre deux garçons
chez lui ou un autre mais lui il a un
avantage c'est un brave type est pour
toi qui aime bien commander ça je te
garantis que si je les pousse toi qui
n'obéissent
[Musique]
e